a big part of the reason that it's so
tough to to sincerely legislate on
immigration is because you've got the
leader of the Republican Party who is
paring Nazi and Hitler in talking about
how immigrants are poisoning the blood
of the nation for faran Arizona has
borne the brunt of federal en action on
our Southern border and I'm tired of it
now is not the time for partisan
politics it's time for Action that's the
Democratic governor by the way Democrats
remain sharply divided when it comes to
the Border you got Governor H ktie Hobbs
calling out the federal government for
an action finally Texas Congressman Wen
Castro delusional points to president
Trump's language so what's it take for
the party if they can't get together on
the border with the Democratic president
especially as it remains a top issue for
voters look at the poll second only to
the economy let's bring in the
Washington Free Beacon contributor Noah
Pollock Noah there was a time in which
that was a republican issue not anymore
it is so bad now you can't put into
words where's this conversation going
now first on the
left I would I would say that there's a
big split this is one of several issues
including the war in Israel um with
Hamas um where there's just a a rift
opening up between the progressive wing
of the democratic party and I would say
Democrats who really would like to win
elections um and the border is really
this kind of open wound and I don't
think the kind of weird weirdly honest
statements by those we just saw from
from representative Castro for example
where he basic said with with total
cander that um the reason we're not
willing to take any action on this
problem that is incredibly destructive
for the country millions of people
flowing uh across the border is because
Donald Trump says things we don't like
and he's he talks about the need to
crack down on the border so we can't do
anything that to me is a deeply
unserious way to handle an issue of this
magnitude no kidding uh how about this
the Democratic mayor of New York he used
to be a Biden disciple he visited it 10
times he can't get anywhere he says this
is an absolute crisis and now we have
the city council in we have the citizens
in inner city Chicago demanding to get
rid of the sanctuary uh status of that
state
now right it's like this amazing
collision between the virtue signaling
wing of the party and the wing of the
party that wants to win elections and
The Virtue signalers um continue being
virtue signalers until the problem is at
their doorstep which is what you're
seeing when politicians in Illinois and
in Chicago New York and even you know
Martha's Vineyard a while back um end up
with the illegal immigration problem um
uh at their own doorstep and all of a
sudden um they get they get sort of very
realistic about the problem um but the
the real issue here is is Biden and I
think that the re one of the reasons
this issue plays so poorly for him is
that it's an illustration of how weak he
is normally a one of the the main things
a president does is he keeps his party
and his Coalition rowing in the same
direction um so that he can win
re-election and so the down ballot um
races are successful for his party um
and this is one where the issue cannot
be dealt with and just festers because
Biden doesn't have the juice inside of
his own party to just stand up to the
activists who are demanding this and say
no guys we're going to actually have a
real policy here that doesn't alienate
the majority of the country no what I'll
be dispassionate about the whole thing a
lot of the issues that Donald Trump
talked about in 2016 are even more ripe
today when it comes to a strong foreign
policy isolating Iran not the rest of
the Middle East uh always staying with
Israel and they at the border when no
one was talking about the Border they
were afraid to talk about the Border
because they're afraid of being labeled
anti-hispanic he dove in and now in 2024
he can honestly say I have a track
record on this how does that play out
for the following
year I there's like I think you you you
you rais a very interesting thing which
is that there's like a Common Thread
running through a lot of these problems
right whether it's the the the rise of
crime and homelessness in cities whether
it's the illegal immigration whether
it's frankly you know Iranian sponsored
attacks on us allies and on
International Shipping in the Middle
East and the common threat is that
Democrats can't seem to stand up to Bad
actors um it's it's it's the I think the
perception and it's a correct perception
of a lot of Voters is that this is the
chaos party um they can't say no these
are all like solvable problems it's
actually not that hard to reduce crime
in cities you have to arrest people um
it's not that hard to stop like Iranian
terrorists from launching missiles at
ships you have to maybe attack retaliate
when they do that and they will stop um
none of the there's no like Innovation
needed to to address these problems um
but they can't do
it it's for me the complexity of stem
cell research when you see Nancy Reagan
separating from George Bush and wow you
really got to think about what this
means and how how it messes with your
faith that to me is one of those issues
these are these are very easy issues
that they're choosing not to solve and
their way of implementing their programs
has been a disaster for the country so
that means it's all preventable no apoll
thanks so much appreciate your Insight
I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm
Angley aart and click here to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page to catch
our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis